>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Good morning.
My name is Virgil Dobjanschi. I am a software
engineer at Google.
I work in the Android Application Group.
I am also the author, more recently, of the
official Twitter app.
I want to welcome you to the session today.
We are going to talk about the development
of REST client applications.
Before we begin, I would like to invite you
to view live notes and ask questions during
this session by using Google Wave.
I am going to give you just a few seconds
to write down this URL if you haven't done
that already.
While you are doing that, I just want to gauge
your opinion about the Froyo announcement.
Were you guys impressed by this announcement,
by everything we announced today in the keynote?
[ Applause ]
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Well, I work in that
group, and I am impressed. I'm amazed by the
amount of stuff that happens in that group.
And I invite you to go to all the other Android
sessions this afternoon, learn about Android
cloud-to-device messaging and all the other
great lessons you can learn and you can use
when you are developing Android applications.
So we have a lot of content to cover, so let's
get started.
So what is REST? REST stands for representational
state transfer. It is a broadly adopted architecture
style. This style is comprised of clients
and servers.
Clients make request to the server to get
or change the state of a particular resource.
Servers respond to the client with representations
of resource.
So what is a resource? A resource is any meaningful
concept that can be addressed. For the purpose
of this talk, I am going to reference back
to the Google Finance API as a simple example
of an API.
So a resource in case of the Google Finance
API is a stock portfolio, which is characterized
by its name and the currency in which it operates.
The representation of the resource is simply
a document that fully describes that particular
resource. In the case of Google Finance API,
it's an XML document which simply describes
that particular resource in terms of its name
and the currency, and maybe its ID for the
purpose of referring to that particular resource
later on when you need to update it or you
need to delete it.
REST is in no way associated with HTTP. You
can use any transport protocol. But certainly
HTTP is the most common used transport protocol
for the REST-style architectures.
There are a large number of REST APIs available
today. Google code offers already a host of
such APIs.
Social networking sites, such as Twitter,
Facebook, MySpace, already have a very rich
REST API. You can find all kinds of information-based
REST services for calendars, for flight schedules
and so forth.
The first question you are going to ask yourself
before you start the development of a REST
client application is why would I possibly
develop an application like that if the service
that I am connecting to already has a mobile-friendly
Web site. In other words, why don't I just
use the browser to connect to that service
and I'm done?
Well, until the browser technology catches
up, I have five reasons for you. I hope I
can remember them all.
The first one is that your application, your
Android application, will be able to integrate
with the Android platform. It will be able
to use intents content providers. It's going
to be able to access all the private APIs
available today, only to Android applications,
things that at least at this point you can't
do from a browser.
Your application will be able to invoke intents,
not only to pick photos but all the other
intents that are today available for all the
applications to use.
The second reason is, your application can
offer intents to other applications. In other
words, you are going to be able to enrich
the behavior of the platform by offering new
functionality to other applications. Content
providers are there for you to access. The
context content provider is a very popular
content provider. Lots of applications expose
it.
The second reason is your applications can
run in the background. What does that mean?
It means that if you would like to have your
application refresh the data from the server
and new data is actually retrieved from the
server, your application has the option to
present a notification to the user to let
them know that that particular data is available.
A browser can't do that.
Your application runs on devices with limited
connectivity. What does that mean? You are
going to try to initiate some of the REST
methods, and they will sometimes fail because
you operate in environments just like here
at the conference where the network comes
and goes.
An Android application has the option to run
in the background and retry operations in
the background by using an alarm, for example,
for the purpose of relieving the user for
trying to hit that refresh button or post
button in the browser.
Your application can actually be faster than
a Web browser. Your application has the option
of retrieving all that network content in
JSON or some binary or some XML format, parse
it and store it in a database. From there
on, when you want to retrieve new content,
you may have the option of retrieving only
content that's newer than the one that you
already have or older than the one you already
have, but not the same data.
You also are not retrieving all the HTML that
comes along or any kind of JavaScript that
might be too big and might take too long to
download.
Finally, your application has the option of
being consistent in terms of user interface
with the REST of the operating system. You
can innovate in many ways to deliver a fantastic
user experience to the user.
If you have participated yesterday in the
user experience talk, please take advantage
of those UI patterns. Your application is
going to be so much faster and easier in some
cases to use than the browser.
And finally, when users are presented with
the option of using a Web browser versus a
REST application, I can guarantee you that
most users will choose the REST application.
Before we begin, I would like to describe
the way a novice programmer would approach
the development of a REST application. That's
not you. You guys know it all, but just for
the purpose of this discussion, let's look
at these things.
Hopefully, it won't take you 10,000 tries
to get there. But I can tell you that I make
these mistakes myself. It's actually human
nature to try to learn as little as you can
about a particular thing and move quickly
forward and say, okay, I am going to have
this app ready in ten minutes. And I am going
to say slow down. Get all the facts first.
Learn what's correct. Implement it correctly
so you have a good base for your application
to get going.
So you are a Java programmer. You have looked
around the Android SDK a little bit, and you
say to yourself, I know what an activity is.
How hard would it be? I am just going to create
this activity.
I understand a REST method takes a long time
to execute because I need to connect to a
server, so I am going to run it in the context
of a thread.
You decide that this thread is going to be
an inner class of your activity. And you decide
that you are going to store all this data
that you retrieve from the server in memory.
Maybe the application I am describing here
is your attempt at displaying the list of
stock portfolios that I already have set up
for my own account in Google Finance.
So you get your application to run. It runs
fast, it doesn't crash. So why is this not
the correct approach?
You have to understand how the Android operating
system works. The Android operating system
was designed to work on devices with limited
memory. What does that mean?
It means that, for example, when the operating
system is attempting to start a new application
and it ran out of memory, it needs to make
a decision about forcefully shutting down
an existing application. So how does it make
that decision?
Well, the answer is you have to help the operating
system make that decision.
If your application does not have a foreground
activity running -- in other words, a visible
activity running -- or a service running,
the operating system can say, okay, well,
this application is not currently displayed
to the user, it's not currently performing
any operation, so it's safe to shut it down.
So let's now go back to our diagram and try
to understand what's wrong with this picture
here.
Well, here's what happens here. You launch
the thread that initiates the REST method,
and guess what? You pause your activity because
maybe an incoming call needs to be answered.
What happens is the operating system says,
oh, well, this particular process doesn't
have any foreground activity, so you know
what? I am going to kill it. I am going to
forcefully shut it down.
Well, guess what? Your post, put, delete method
maybe has executed on the server and you will
never learn the result of that particular
method in your app.
The get method, you get all this data in,
once you get it in, you parse it, you are
happy, the operating system will shut it down
for you. Wasted bandwidth.
Another thing that's wrong with your approach
is that you decided to store the data in memory.
So you say, well, hang on. My application
is fast.
Well, the reason why that's not a good idea,
it's because by having to repeatedly retrieve
data from the server, either because the user
has simply restarted the device or simply
because at one point your process had to be
forcefully shut down, you are wasting CPU,
you are wasting battery, you are wasting network
bandwidth.
That's not a great way to write an Android
application.
And for those of you who are going to say,
well, it's much faster to get this data from
memory, I am going to say by using a content
provider, you have the option, should you
consider that necessary, to cache this data
on memory.
So that's really not a good reason to say
I'm not going to store my data.
As I said, none of you will probably write
the application this way.
So let's describe today three design patterns
that you can use in your applications that
would give the best user experience and the
best performance. These are not the only three
patterns you can use.
Once you look at them, once you understand
what they are all about, you can possibly
create your own. That's great.
As long as your application complies with
the basic principles that we're laying here
for you, it's okay to continue to innovate
from here.
We're not going to talk about implementation
details. I am not going to show you code.
Hopefully you like that.
So let's introduce these three patterns. One
is based on the service API, one is based
on the content provider API, and the third
one is simply a variant of the second one.
We are going to use a sync adapter.
This is an advanced talk. Last year we got
a lot of feedback from you guys saying some
of the sessions were too light. We decided
to compensate this year.
Even though it's an advanced slide, I am going
to try to introduce these concepts which some
of you may not be familiar with so you understand
the basic idea behind it.
So let's get started with the first pattern.
The first pattern makes use of a service.
Again, for those of how are not familiar with
a service, it's an Android component that
does not interact with a user, and it's specifically
designed to execute operations in the background.
It runs in the context of the main thread.
We can call that the UI thread.
And in order for you to execute these operations,
you need to still create a worker thread in
the service.
Some people think that by simply starting
the service, I can simply execute in the context
of the thread of the service that particular
long-running operations. That's false.
So now that we understand that the service
exists in the platform and has, by the way,
a very simple API. You can either implement
the services API by using an intent API or
by using a binder interface. By the way, for
the purpose of this talk, we are going to
use the intent API which is, by the way, a
little bit easier to understand.
We can now get started with this first pattern.
This diagram is not exactly simple. To best
understand it, we are going to take a bottom-to-top
approach by explaining the role of each component.
And once we are done, we are going to do one
example starting from the top and running
through an entire code flow to see how this
works.
So let's get started with the REST method.
What is the REST method? Really simple. It's
an entity which has the ability to prepare
an HTTP URL, to prepare the HTTP body in some
cases, execute the HTTP transaction with the
server and process the response, which typically
means parse the response from the server.
There's not much to say about this. Let's
make some performance remarks.
Many REST APIs offer today the ability that
you select the content type of responses.
Prefer them in this order. Some binary format,
AMF3, whatever is out there, JSON and XML.
We are happy to announce that if you choose
JSON, we have a brand-new implementation of
org.json API. It has exactly the same API
as before but it performs much faster.
There is very little garbage collection going
on. For those of you who tried the older version,
you are going to be very happy with this particular
implementation.
Enable gzip. If the REST API that you are
using allows it.
Gzip is a very fast library. It's a native
implementation. Sometimes you get compression
ratio five to one, ten to one, depending how
much data you are retrieving.
And by doing so, you are simply speeding up
the download of data that you want, plus the
battery life will be preserved better in this
case because the radio will be in use for
less amount of time.
Always think about the radio, always think
about the network and the implication it has
on the battery life of that particular device.
Always run this REST method in a worker thread.
Understand that an HTTP transaction takes
time to implement, sometimes a long time if
a timeout occurs. And you should never run
such operations in the context of the main
thread.
And finally, use the Apache HTTP client, not
the Java URL connection.
All right. So what do we have so far? We have
the REST method, a simple API. It fires back
a Java listener callback. Really simple.
Let's take a look at the processor.
The role of the processor is to mirror the
state of server resources in your local database.
We're going to use the database. The role
of the processor is to say, okay, this is
the state of this particular resource.
So to better understand how the processor
works, we need to create this concept of a
resource in the database.
Well, it's really simple. It's exactly one
row in the database. In the case of Google
Finance, it's a row that maybe has the idea
of this particular resource, the name of this
particular portfolio, and the currency. And
we are going to add two more columns to that.
One, a status column, and, two, a result column.
The status column is the one that simply indicates
the transitional slash at-REST or steady state
of that particular resource. What that means
is that every resource, when it executes a
REST method, has a transitional state; right?
While you are executing this particular transaction,
the resource is not yet in sync with the server
so we want to keep track of this particular
state.
Your question is why. Why would I possibly
need this? Two reasons.
One, your user interface may want to display
maybe a little icon next to the resource that
says, oh, well, you know, I don't have to
stay in the activity that actually started
this post, the creation of the portfolio.
I can just leave that activity. And my list
of items is just going to display a little
icon next to that particular resource saying
I'm in the process of synchronizing the resource,
but go ahead and use the app. I will let you
know when that's done.
When that disappears, that's a good indication
that your resource has now been synchronized.
So in the standard set of these, we are going
to hold some flags. These flags are going
to say I am in the process of executing a
post method for this particular resource.
I am in the process of updating, deleting
this particular resource.
And we are going to use one more flag to say
we are in the process of executing an HTTP
transaction for this REST method.
Now you have a full description of anything
what's going on. At any time you can look
at the database and say, okay, I know exactly
what's going on with this particular resource.
The result method can simply hold the HTTP
result of the last REST method you executed
in regards to that particular resource.
So now let's come back to the processor.
The processor executes before and after the
REST method executes.
Before the REST method executes, in case of
the post method, it's simply going to insert
the content -- it's going to create a row
in the database, it's going to call an insert
method to create the row that corresponds
to the resource we need to update.
We are going to set the flags to posting,
meaning we're in the process of executing
a post method for this particular resource.
We're going to say yep. We are also transacting,
by the way, so we are going to set that flag,
too, in the column, and we initiative the
REST method.
We are going to update the row in the database
with the help of the content provider. We
are going to clear the state posting fire
because that particular method is no longer
pending, and we are also going to clear the
transacting flag so we know we are no longer
transacting the server.
Put works very similarly. It's hardly worth
going through this, but we're going to update
before the (inaudible) execute, we are going
to update this particular row in the database.
We are going to set the updating flag, meaning
we're in the process of updating this resource
on the server. Set the transaction flag, execute
the REST method. Once it's done, update it
again, and clear the two flags that we just
set, if everything goes right.
By the way, as you well know, most correction
REST API implementations are item potent.
It means that you want to send a document
to the server saying, okay, I want to change
the state of this particular resource on the
server, and you send this document representing
the change you want to make, and the response
that comes back, it's the full description
of that particular resource as the server
sees it. In other words, the state on the
server side.
That's why it's recommended that you go ahead
and update again, although many times that's
not necessary. It's up to you to decide. But
either way, in this case you are going to
have to clear the flags.
Delete. Very simple. You are just going to
delete -- tag that particular method for deletion.
You are not actually going to delete the resource.
Why? Because we have not yet successfully
executed the REST method.
You go ahead, execute the REST method. It
succeeds finally, you delete that row.
Finally, you are done.
Your user interface, by the way, in this case,
has the option of saying, well, you know what?
If the state deleting flag is set in the status
column, I am not even going to bother displaying
that particular resource. Or you have the
option to display a little synchronizing resource
right next to that particular resource to
know that we have not yet deleted it but we
are about to.
By the way, these flags can serve a different
purpose.
What happens when you need to retry these
operations? Well, wouldn't it be great to
know what exactly do you need do. The posting
flag would mean, oh, I need to execute a post
method. I am going to look at the transacting
flag saying is there an HTTP transaction already
posting?
So if that's the case, I am not going to start
another one.
If it's not, I have the option of saying,
okay, well, let me retry this. Maybe the network
didn't work last time.
But that's a great way to mirror the state
of the resource in the database and retry
these methods.
Get, simplest one of all. There's nothing
to do. Processor has nothing to do before
the REST method inserts the new resources
it wants to get from the server.
This could be the list of stock portfolios,
maybe you have many of them on Google Finance.
One more thing to say about processors. They
execute database operations. Never execute
database operations or content provider operations
in the context of the main thread. Sooner
or later you are going to run into application
not responding errors. The so-called ANRs.
It's not a good practice.
Learn to stay away from that.
Also, use transactions when you SQL light.
Not only will they preserve the data integrity
but they will increase the performance of
your database operations.
We have the processor, we have the REST method.
The processor has almost the same API as the
REST method, it goes through. But this time
we are able to mirror the state of that particular
resource in the database.
We said at the beginning that it's not a good
idea to start long-running operations in that
activity. That's where the service comes in.
The role of the service is to simply allow
your application to execute operations in
the background while an activity is long gone.
I am going to say it again. An activity comes
and goes. It's just the user interface of
your application.
The user has the option to hit the home button,
hit the destroy button -- in other words,
go back home.
Your long running operation, it's still executing.
And the nice thing is that you have the database.
Simply store the state of that particular
resource in the database and when you come
back to your application, regardless of what
happened, you can simply learn what happened.
Did it work? Is it still pending? What's going
on?
On the forward path, the service simply receives
an intent. We said we were going to use the
intent-based API. It unpacks the content of
that intent, which think of it as a map. Oh,
yeah, I passed in, for example, the name of
this particular stock portfolio and the currency.
I am going to extract it from there. Make
a Java call to the processor. Done.
On the return path, I am simply going to handle
the processor callback, and I am going to
invoke what is called a binder callback. What
is a binder callback? The binder callback,
think of it as an interface that was passed
in the request intent.
So the upper layer says when you are done
with this particular operation, I want you
to invoke this binder callback and let me
know that everything worked or failed.
Here is another thing you can do in the service.
You write a social application. And all of
a sudden your UI needs to download ten, 20
images just because you are scrolling really
fast through that list.
Is it a good idea to download 10, 20 little
images at the same time? The answer is no.
Be nice to all the other applications. They
might need the bandwidth at that time.
Implement a little queue in this particular
service. Allow maybe one, two, or three, as
it is the case in your application, for parallel
downloads of these particular images, especially
if these particular images are larger.
Always think about the other apps when you
are writing one.
And finally, the service is a stateless component.
Everything it needs, it receives the intent.
Fires the callback. Unless you implement the
queue we were just talking about for downloads,
there's no reason to keep any state. And most
importantly, while all the pending operations
have completed, shut down the service.
If you don't, the operating system is going
to say, well, this guy is busy. You know,
let him keep the memory that it wants. Let
him do whatever he needs to do.
Be nice, again, to all the other applications.
Shut down the service once you are done. It's
very easy. We are going to say for the purpose
of the service helper to stop the service
or the service can stop itself. There are
many ways to do it. You have no excuse to
leave that service running.
Almost there.
We have a service with an intent API, and
asynchronously fires a binder callback interface.
Sometimes preparing these intents is not that
easy. Or at least not elegant. I know that.
And handling the binder callback is not something
we should leave as an exercise for the reader.
What we should do is have a very thin layer,
we call this the service helper, that prepares
these intents for us on the forward path and
handles the binder callback on the return
path.
So the role of the service helper is to simply
expose a very simple asynchronous API to the
caller. Let's say we want to create a portfolio.
The name of the method is create portfolio,
here is my name, here is the currency. It
returns the request ID, which uniquely identifies
that particular pending REST method.
It's a Singleton. There's nothing to it. You
make this call and here is what the service
does.
It's much simpler than it looks.
The first thing you may want to do is have
the ability to ask the question is this particular
REST method already pending? That's certainly
not the case with create. But if you do maybe
a get my stock portfolio list, what if you
issue this request and some other activity
which quickly you switch to issues yet another
request.
Well, you certainly don't want this particular
situation where, let's say, you are downloading
and parsing the stock portfolios in parallel
in two different threads. It makes no sense.
So you can protect yourself in this particular
pattern here in the service helper. You can
implement the map from the request ID to the
this intent. And you can always, first of
all, ask the service is this particular request
ID still pending?
You can do something else. You can look at
the values, the intents in the values method
and say by looking at the intents you will
be able to answer the question is this particular
type of operation, maybe even with these parameters,
already pending? And if yes, you simply return
that request ID to the user and it's a nice
way to get around some of these problems.
And finally, you put the operation type, you
put any method-specific parameters such as
the name and the currency. You set the binder
callback and you finally call start service
which simply sends that service to the service
that we discussed earlier.
On the return path, really easy. You get the
binder callback, and this time you say, okay,
this particular operation is no longer pending.
And you can dispatch a callback to any listeners.
Listeners are typically going to be activities
that would like to know the result of this
particular REST method.
One interesting discussion here is what kind
of data should I pass from the service to
the service helper? And you are going to say,
okay, you just retrieved that list of stock
portfolios. Should I just pass it on? Should
I just move all that data through this particular
binder callback?
Well, think of it as a marshaling interface.
In other words, something that has to cross
process boundaries.
Well, you don't want to do that. Keep as little
data as possible in that particular callback.
For example, you can say the result of this
particular REST method was 200. Okay. You
can say here is, by the way, the original
intent which I used to start this operation.
Maybe the caller would like to analyze the
content of that particular intent to remind
itself what it was executing at that time.
All the day that you already retrieved, it's
already in the database. The activity has
the option of simply saying, okay, thanks
for letting me know. I am going to go and
retrieve that content.
There's absolutely no harm done if you choose
once in a while to pass some data through
this binder interface.
You can use any parcel-able, think of it as
serialization technique, to send data over
this interface.
The less data you parcel, the better it is.
So we are almost done. The service helper
has a simple API. If there are any listeners
that register, these calls go back to the
activity.
Let's look at the activity.
Always remember the activities are pause,
resume, or destroy. They have their own mind.
They have, better said, their own life cycle.
Think of them again as just user interface
that is either controlled by the user. In
some cases activities pop in front of your
application just because maybe a phone call
comes in, in which case the application will
be paused, the activity will be paused.
And on resume, we have the option of adding
a callback to the service, say, okay, I'm
back.
I'm interested in what you have to say.
On pause, remove that, because if a callback
will occur while your activity is paused,
sooner or later, you'll get a crash.
You're trying to access this activity while
it's paused, and that's certainly an incorrect
technique.
Always consider these three cases.
A request method is started by the activity.
The activity just sits there in the foreground.
Everything is nice, it gets the callback from
the service helper.
Easy.
You, in case of an error, you can say, I'm
sorry, I couldn't perform your operation.
Or, hey, cool, we created the stock portfolio.
What if the activity starts the REST method,
pauses, it comes back, it resumes, and now
the callback occurs.
Well, that's not much more difficult.
However, you can still handle the callback.
Everything is great.
You -- in this case, you may need to store
the request ID so you know to ask the service
helper, is this particular request still pending?
And so -- and on resume, the answer this time
is going to say, yep, that's still pending.
Okay.
So I'll just wait for the call back.
Nothing special.
Third one is the most complex.
REST method is started.
Activity's paused.
REST method completes while the activity is
paused.
Activity comes back to life and resumes.
What's happening?
Well, in unresume this time you're going to
have again the request ID that you started,
and you'll say is this request still running,
and the answer is going to be no, it's not.
So now you understand why we chose to store
the result in the database.
The application has the option to go back
to the database and figure out exactly what
happened with this particular pending request
while it was maybe destroyed, maybe paused,
and so on.
Remember, that operation -- that long-running
operation, the REST method, was running, because
it executed in the content of a service, and
the operating system said, "Okay, I'm good,
just going to leave this particular process
alone, because it's executing what it thinks
it's important."
So that's great.
On the return path, here we have the option
to receive callbacks from the ContentProvider
itself.
The ContentProvider supports what's called
content observers.
Content observers are simple ways to receive
notifications from the ContentProvider when
data changes for a particular set of entries
in a particular table.
That's a simple explanation, but that should
do.
In other words, you can monitor the status
of a particular row or maybe all the rows,
all the resources in that database.
We reached the top.
Let's go -- take a full example and run with
it.
The activity decides to create a portfolio.
It says, okay, I'm going to call the simple
method in the service helper called "create
portfolio."
The service helper says, okay, I'm going to
-- new intent, packet everything I need,
the name of the service, the currency, the
binder callback, the type of operation, I'm
creating a portfolio, the unique request ID.
It calls start service.
It says this particular operation is pending
and returns the request ID to the caller.
The caller has the option to use this particular
request idea to find out if this particular
REST method is still pending.
Finally, the intent gets the service, the
service unpacks it, makes a Java call to the
processor.
The processor said, what kind of method corresponds
to this particular Java method?
Oh, this is a POST, I need to create a new
stock portfolio.
So I'm going to go and insert that content
into the database, in other words, I'm going
to create a row in the database.
I'm going to set the status posting, I'm going
to set the transaction flag in the status
column and I'm going to say, okay, I'm ready
to execute my REST method.
The REST method prepares the URI parameters,
prepares the request body, if that's required
-- and for Google Finance, that's certainly
the case -- gets the callback once the REST
method transacts with the server, it obviously
gets the parts resolved back from the REST
method.
The processor says, okay, I'm going to update
the state of this particular resource in the
database.
So it updates the content, it updates the
flag by saying, okay, this particular method
is no longer pending.
We assume, obviously, that it worked.
And the ContentProvider, with fire notifications
as needed, if there are any kind of content
observers.
On the return path, processor says to the
service, thank you.
I'm done.
Service says, okay, I'm going to invoke the
binder callback that was already in the intent.
And, finally, if the service -- service helper
sales, you know what?
This REST method is no longer pending.
I'm going to let any activities know about
the result.
And the activities have the option to handle
that callback and display to the users and
so forth.
So that's a quick run through this particular
design pattern.
Next one.
Based on a ContentProvider API.
What is a ContentProvider?
For those of you who don't know, it's a simple
way in Android to store and retrieve data
across process boundaries.
Typically, a ContentProvider sits in front
of the database.
It offers the insert, update, delete, and
query methods that, in the end, access the
database.
Really simple stuff.
I can go into details.
Hopefully, that explanation will be sufficient
for the purpose of this discussion.
So the first question you're going to have
from me, okay, how in the world did you get
to the conclusion that you can use a ContentProvider
API to initiate REST methods?
Well, the answer is simple.
There's a one-to-one mapping between REST
method types and method -- some of the methods
in the ContentProvider.
So the get REST method corresponds to query
in the database.
The POST REST method corresponds to insert.
The PUT REST method corresponds to update.
And, finally, the DELETE REST method corresponds
to delete.
Really simple.
It's not hard to imagine how this works.
So here's the pattern that we can use.
Let's say -- By the way, in this particular
diagram, the service helper, the service,
the REST method work just as before.
The ContentProvider and the processor have
a slightly different functionality, and we
can cover that once we go through an entire
flow to this particular diagram.
So let's assume as before that we would like
to create a stock portfolio.
The activity says, okay, this is going to
be a creation, so that corresponds to a POST.
Obviously, I'm going to do an insert.
It calls the insert -- prepares the content
values.
For those of you who are not familiar, it's
just a way to specify the values that you
would like to insert in specific columns in
the ContentProvider.
Calls insert.
ContentProvider says, okay, I'm going to create
this row for you.
And before it returns, however, it does a
trick and says, "I understand that this particular
operation needs to execute a POST REST method."
So it initiates, with the help of the service
helper, the POST method.
It returns the URI for the new list -- the
caller, the activity in this case.
It says, okay, I inserted for you, and by
the way, I'm going to keep the transactional
state for this particular resource.
The state posting will be on, the transactional
flag -- transactioning flag will be on.
And, finally, the activity has the option
to use these flags, should it need, to display
the status of this particular resource while
it's transitioning in the UI.
That's up to the application.
Or choose not to so this it at all, or, you
know, whatever policy would like to institute.
Finally, the service helper calls the service,
executes the REST method.
Once the REST method is successful, executes.
The processor says, okay.
Because the REST method succeed, I'm going
to clear these flags, update the row.
And the activity, maybe a cursor adapter,
any content observer, will have the ability
to understand that this particular -- the
status of this particular resource has been
updated.
By the way, in this case, if the REST method
fails, it's up -- it's the responsibility
of the ContentProvider to say, okay, I'm going
to set up an alarm here, and maybe after five
minutes, I'm going to retry it.
And maybe I'll implement some nice exponential
backoff so I don't keep retrying, you know,
and kill the battery in the process of doing
so.
Please note that in this particular pattern,
we broke the ContentProvider contract a little
bit.
For insert and update, everything works as
expected.
You're calling insert.
We insert the resource right away into the
database as a row.
For update, we do the same thing.
We update the resource as the database -- forget,
we do something funny.
In other words, for query, we do something
funny.
We go to the database first.
We'll get the rows that already exist.
Now we have a cursor, and this is the cursor
that a query typically returns to the caller.
Now, if the activity would like to retrieve
brand-new, fresh content from the server,
it has the option in the query URI to set
a flag and say, I would like to also get the
latest data from the server.
So the ContentProvider says, okay, not only
am I going to give you the results in the
cursor, but also I'm going to let the service
helper know that it's time to execute a get
method maybe in the refresh mode to say, just
give me items that are newer than the one
I have.
Delete breaks the contract.
For delete, you say, I'm going to just tag
this row for deletion.
I'm not going to delete it right away.
And, finally, the row gets deleted once the
particular delete REST method has completed.
It's not a big deal.
You just need to think about it.
And maybe once you display your results in
a list activity with a cursor, again look
at the flag to see what is the state of that
particular resource in the database there.
There are other ways to do this.
You can remove the row from the database,
possibly move it to another table where you're
going to be able to retry delete requests.
Again, we're not forcing you to adopt these
particular design patterns.
The last pattern is simply a variant of the
previous one.
We're still going to use the ContentProvider
API.
But we're going to use the help of a sync
adapter.
How many of you know what a sync adapter is?
I was afraid of that.
The sync adapter is a concept that you should
learn as soon as you get home and you start
developing for applications.
What it is is the ability of the system to
help you synchronize remote and local content.
The system employs the help of a service manager
-- I'm sorry, a sync manager.
The sync manager manages all the sync adapters
across all apps.
The sync adapters are simply services started
by the sync manager.
The sync manager implements a queue of sync
adapters.
In other words, if you say I would like to
sync my data, there's a request sync method
in the sync manager.
It does not mean that the sync manager will
say, sure, right away.
What it does instead, it queues the execution
of this particular adapter behind any other
sync adapters that need to execute.
By the way, even if the queue is empty, the
sync manager has the option of saying, okay.
I'll get to it.
Why does it do that?
Why doesn't the sync manager just run out
there and start your sync operation right
away?
Well, the reason is, is because it's trying
to preserve the integrity of the entire system.
What if you start your GMail sync with an
e-mail sync, you develop your own app.
All of a sudden you have four apps executing
these sync operations in parallel.
They all do network transactions.
They all do parsing.
They all do database operations.
It's a mess.
Don't do that.
Also, when you -- obviously, the sync adapter
is going to help you, it's going to prevent
you from getting into that trouble.
But the characteristic of a sync adapter is
that it does not execute maybe as fast as
you would like to.
So with that in mind, let's look at this pattern.
Activity works the same way.
You need to create a stock portfolio.
You call insert into the ContentProvider.
The ContentProvider creates that row in the
database that sets its -- a transitional state
to whatever it needs to be.
That's it.
It returns to say thank you, I'm done.
So how does the REST method execute?
That's where the sync adapter comes in.
Well, I lied.
The ContentProvider, before returning, calls
request sync.
It says, when you have a chance, come back
to me, start my sync adapter.
The sync adapter starts, looks in the database,
and asks, are there any resources that are
in the transitional state at this point?
Yes.
Here's our resource.
It needs to be posted.
It goes, reads the row from the database,
starts the REST method, executes it, gets
the result, updates the database, and says
done.
What if it fails?
Well, awesome.
The sync adapters have the ability to handle
errors nicely, in other words, I should say
the sync manager.
The sync adapter is responsible for simply
throwing errors back to the sync manager.
The sync manager says, hmm, there was an error
while I tried to sync this, you know what,
by implementing exponential backoff, I'll
queue this particular sync adapter behind
any others, if any, and I'm going to restart
this sync when I have a chance.
All of that is already there for you.
You don't have to write your code with alarms.
You don't have to do all this stuff.
All you have to do is learn how to report
errors from the sync adapter to the sync manager.
All our applications use the content of the
sync adapter to refresh content.
GMail, e-mail, all these apps use that particular
concept.
Please use it in your apps.
In conclusion, please do not implement REST
methods inside activities.
It's poor practice.
An activity is a piece of user interface.
It's no different than any other Java framework
you work with.
It's -- there's a clear separation there between
user -- user interface and functionality.
Always start a long-running operations from
a service.
Also, always stop the service while -- if
all the pending transactions have completed.
Always remember that the service executes
in the context of the main thread.
If you need to execute these long-running
operations, start a worker thread in order
to execute these operations.
SQLite is your friend.
Persist early and persist often.
What does that mean?
POST PUT insert as soon as you can.
Update is as soon as you can.
Once you get the result, do it again, if you
think that's a smart thing to do.
Please don't let your database grow infinitely.
Think about this: You keep getting new items
from the server.
And all of a sudden your table holds thousands,
tens of thousands, of items.
Well, your database grows.
It is the responsibility of your application
to possibly purge old data.
Why is that a good idea?
Not only because the user will be mad at you
because you made their phone useless, but
because the cursor has the ability to hold
only about one megabyte of data.
Beyond one megabyte, it will have to do windowing,
which is a very slow operation.
Don't hold a lot of data in these cursors.
For example, images.
If you use images in your cursor, which absolutely
you could, what you're doing is, you're taking
away from your ability to store more items
in a cursor.
Minimize network usage.
Only request data that's newer than the one
you have.
Older than the one you have, but don't go
back to the server and get that one again.
Page data.
If you don't page data, you are retrieving
this huge amount of data from the server.
It takes time.
You parse it, takes a lot of time to parse
it. You insert it in a database.
That application will never perform fast enough.
Always use paging.
Hosting, the REST API that you're using sports
paging.
Finally, use a sync adapter to synchronize
the content of your local database with the
state of your server.
We're very happy to announce here at Google
I/O that the Android cloud-to-device message
is now available.
You won't have to set up an alarm in order
to continuously start the sync adapter and
ask the server, are you done?
Do you have new data?
Use the push notification.
Of course it takes an effort on your behalf.
I warmly recommend this afternoon's session
on the Android cloud-to-device messaging.
I would save a lot of battery life for a particular
phone when using this technology.
If you use all these techniques in your REST
method and you create your own, -- let us
know, by the way, we're happy to hear from
you -- you will create awesome REST client
applications, very performant, and the user
will simply enjoy using it maybe over a Web
browser that accesses that same service.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So I'll take some questions
now.
>>> Excuse me?
>>> Ladies and gentlemen, if you have any
questions, please go to the microphone, and
we'll be with you in a moment.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So any questions?
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
>>> Yes, I have actually two questions.
One is, what are the advantages of intent-based
service invocations versus AIDL?
And second is, would the person need to approve
the sync adapter in the settings account and
sync UI for your sync adapter to work?
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: I need you to repeat
the second question.
>>> The second part is, the -- would user
have to explicitly approve your sync adapter
in the settings UI for your sync adapter to
work?
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So the answer to the
second question is yes.
One of the nice things about the sync adapter,
it obeys the user settings on a per-account
basis, which is fantastic.
Because sync adapters are linked to accounts.
So you can even say I don't want -- the user
can say, I don't want this sync adapter to
run all the time.
You can -- it can select which ones it will
actually run.
Also, it will base the contract of out of
sync and data, let's say you're traveling.
What's going to happen?
Well, you probably didn't subscribe for roaming,
and you don't want your sync to go in the
background.
There's a framework that takes care of that
and it obeys that.
That's one of the great reasons to use a sync
adapter.
>>> So in this question, if ContentProvider
kicked off the sync, but the user have never
yet approved the sync adapter, it will not
sync?
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: It's not a manual -- it's
not one of those permission things.
It's a setting for the platform.
>>> Okay.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So you have to go to
settings and not even in your application
rather than the phone settings and approve
it.
I know you had a first question.
I apologize.
>>> Sure.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: What was the first question?
>>> The first question was, was the advantages
of the intent-based service notification versus
AIDL.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So there's a difference
there.
That's a very complex subject.
Please look at the API of a service.
In order to use the interface, the binding,
you have to actually bind to that service.
You have to connect to it.
That's an asynchronous call.
And you may not want to deal with the complexity
of it.
The intent, on the other hand, it's very simple.
You can say, here's this intent, but note
that that particular operation always executes
asynchronously.
Whereas in the binder call, you have the option
to execute it synchronously.
Poor design by the way, but you have no option
to do so.
>>> Hi. Thank you.
I recently came across a very useful class
called intent service.
And I was wondering if -- I mean, it seems
like this would be a -- like, exactly the
kind of place that you would want to use that
service it.
Handles, like, the threading and everything
automatically.
Do you think that's a good idea or, like,
do you have any recommendations about using
or not using that class?
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: I wanted to simplify
the content of the presentation.
Intent services are great.
If what you want is to execute a long-running
operation in the content of the worker thread,
the intent service can certainly help you
with that.
In our case, however, I don't know if you
picked up on this, everything happens asynchronously.
So I didn't have a huge need for it.
Can you do it?
Absolutely.
And, actually, it's a very good way of not
having to deal yourself to create that particular
worker thread.
It will be created for you.
So, yes, absolutely yes.
>>> Okay.
And I had a second quick question.
You said that you don't need to set a flag
for the get method in your database.
And I'm wondering if I'm missing something
or, like, if there is something that I might
be fetching an update for from the database,
so it's something that already exists in the
-- on the server and I've retrieve it before
and now I want to see if, like, there's some
value in one of the fields and the rows have
changed and I want to see if I'm getting updates
for this row, I would have to set a state
for --
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Is it too late for me
to change that?
No.
Yes, it's a good -- The problem is that you
didn't get anything yet.
What are you setting these flags into?
>>> No, I mean, it's a resource that you have
retrieved, but you want to check to see if,
like, a value in that row has been updated.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: However, the flags I
was describing were specific to a particular
resource, not for items that you haven't yet
retrieved.
That type of status is okay if you store in
memory.
We can -- if you want more, I'm happy to discuss
this with you after.
>>> Okay.
Great.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Thank you.
Let me take a question, actually, from Wave
users.
Unfortunately, we're not going to be able
to show any calls.
Wow.
The question regarding the Apache HTTP client
versus Java.
That's a very good question.
I would simply advise that you use the HTTP
Apache client, because it has a more robust
implementation.
The URL connection type of HTTP transaction
is not the most efficient implementation.
And the way it terminates connections sometimes
can have an adverse effect on the network.
Let's leave it at that.
Sorry.
Let's go.
>>> Yeah, I do have a question on, say, if
you have a search use case in the application,
do you still recommend to persist that in
the database, because user is very unlikely
that he's going to come back and use that
data again at a later stage.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So you're not referring
to search across resources you already have
in the database?
>>> Right, yeah.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: So you're going across
the network.
I'm sorry to say, it's best left to the implementation
of the app.
>>> Okay.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Apps that I worked on
had different requirements.
Because this is a requirement of the user
interface.
For example, should you initiate requests.
>>> As you're typing?
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Should you initiate these
searches at every single key that's being
typed?
Or should you wait until the user has said,
okay, let me search now?
Up to you.
Of course, you're overwhelming the network
with requests once you're doing a search,
especially if you don't have some good policy
in the lower layer to say, "Ignore this response.
Ignore this response," because the user is
still typing.
Otherwise, you keep parsing, you keep inserting
possibly results in the database while the
user is still typing.
So it's probably not the best way to do it.
But there are absolutely -- I have nothing
against that.
>>> Thanks.
>>Virgil Dobjanschi: Sure.
I'm sorry. We have time for one more question.
Not even one.
I'm sorry.
If you have any more questions, please talk
to me right now after the session.
[ Applause ]